this is a story that has gone viral you
probably saw it on social media a crime
fighting k-9 that's right well actually
last friday a truck driver was stopped
for erratic driving in the valley and
special backup was called sally
jaramillo introduces us to nuggets the
pup that sniffed out the stash
day in the life for him is uh i guess
pampered if you will he lives with me
you know he's with me 24 7. he likes to
whine a lot
always anxious to work thomas bachmann
is las vegas metro pd detective he along
with his partner nuggets has been
inseparable since september of 2018.
on friday what appeared to be a typical
traffic stop turned into a major drug
bust the semi truck was located near the
i-15 and saint rose parkway and that's
when nuggets was called into action
nuggets who is strictly a narcotics dog
was able to find 10.5 million worth of
cocaine hidden in a truckload of
tomatoes we ran the exterior of the
vehicle and
lo and behold we got the positive alert
for the amount of narcotics that are on
the streets to be able to take that much
weight off the streets quite significant
bachmann says this was not only a large
bus for police but a big job for nuggets
nugget's bus also went viral when he's
doing a search his ultimate goal is that
he gets his reward
and so he keeps that in the back of his
mind from the minute we get in the car
to the minute we get out to do a sniff
the bond that he and i have
it's my buddy sally caramillo live local
now